is Lana hot car test arena's Petri says
she's excited to be meeting someone new
today because you never know what
they'll be like a woman wonders what's
used to wear in such a first blind date
so she's brought a full selection so she
could decide later on the spur of the
moment in Sidon silcoon robust athletic
minimalistic elegant they're all on hand
and so is her date which aims to capture
her heart with adventure and diversity
hyundai's I 20 active crossover model
it's based on the 5-door version of the
standard i-20 but the designers have
given it a silver underride guard in the
front and rear and black plastic
components on the sides for a look all
its own
penises first impression she likes what
she sees the engineers have raised the
i20 active chassis by 2 centimeters the
cars additional components make it 2
centimeters longer as well will it live
up to its attractive exterior
the roof rails make it possible to carry
additional bulky luggage this is a car
for the active life a dapper gentleman
but also a sportsman
that too of course appearances and
everything says eNOS it's the inner
values that count and in a car that's
the engine here Hyundai has engaged in
downsizing like this sandal this version
has trimmed material away and traded the
1.4 liter engine in for a one liter one
it is wonders how that affects
performance but since the naturally
aspirated engines have been replaced by
turbochargers the car is a little
sporty-er it's now got more torque so it
gets quickly moving scoot any pizza
eanes tested the i20 active with a newly
developed 1 liter turbo petrol engine in
the lower 74 kilowatt performance level
this engine is supposed to consume just
4.8 liters per 100 kilometers it's
advantage is 172 newton meters of torque
available from 1500 RPM on up Hyundai
steers very cooperatively it's agile and
takes every curve well
but eNOS would have liked a bit more
temperament at high speeds she says the
i20 active is demanding when it comes to
shifting gears the five gears need to be
used very actively especially if you
want to get somewhere quickly now she'll
test the Hyundai off-road the crossovers
higher ground clearance enables it to
surmount minor unevenness effortlessly
and the driver sits a bit higher to
which provides a good overview of the
situation but this car is less
adventuresome about daring maneuvers for
example with a wheel up in the air or
very rough ground
that's what the i20 active doesn't have
all wheel drive ena says so forget
roughing it in the mountains
the interior is generously outfitted the
Hyundai has provided the i20 active with
high quality durable surfaces everything
feels good to the touch the metal clad
pedals underscore the i20 active
individual character the car is roomy in
front and back the rear seat sits three
the trunk isn't stingy with space either
even the glove compartment is large
enough to stow penises pumps they unite
this concludes that the Hyundai i20
active is a great all-round vehicle for
everyday use returning to her shoot
theme she remarks that sometimes the
ones you're already wearing are perfect
but just to be sure she'll take your
pumps along I'll snuff moment after all
with this new acquaintance you never
know what adventures waiting around the
bend
by the wine industry our cart estimate
is correct well I was taking a Porsche
on to the racetrack it's something many
people dream of but he expects that the
new 911 Turbo will be even dreamier than
this Porsche bike today he's meeting a
professional racer Porsches factory
driver yard Bergmeister with whom don't
do a few laps but first let's take a
closer look at the elegant speedster
we'll be testing the 911 turbo in the
convertible version at speeds over 120
km/h the front spoiler extends to direct
the airflow around the chassis reducing
uplift hi York Montes and Jorg
Bergmeister exchanged greetings yeah I
Ghana and off they go to the racetrack
the 911 enjoys a long tradition at
Porsche and race driver Jorg Bergmeister
has been involved in much of it
montes notes that this isn't the first
911 Yard has driven York says he first
drove a 964 in the 1994 Porsche Trophy
race and that he's driven every
generation since a 993 the 996 the 997
and now the 991 the current version of
the 911 Turbo produces 397 kilowatts and
660 newton meters of torque that
accelerates the car from 0 to 100
kilometers an hour in just 3.1 seconds a
besides Allah disaster York what's
special about the 911 Turbo at the top
of your list is how much fun it is to
drive the 911 turbo has plenty of power
in every situation lots of torque and a
breathtaking top speed it's just a lot
of fun to drive whether on a racetrack
the highway or in city traffic the car
covers an impressive spectrum of
situations but phlegyas auto-update
design final
the changes to the car's appearance are
minor noticeable probably only two
dyed-in-the-wool Porsche fans but the
output of the turbo and the Turbo S is
14 kilowatts or 20 horsepower higher
than their predecessors get the did not
assess your whether he can feel the
increased power of the new 991 when
driving tightly when found the Osmonds I
got and how it says your increased
torque and more horsepower are
definitely noticeable and the traction
is a little better too he says he can go
from zero to 100 kilometers an hour in
2.9 seconds specs that can leave you
speechless the roof of the 911 turbo
convertible opens in 13 seconds at
speeds up to 50 kilometers an hour the
interior is just as sporty as the
exterior the materials are as high
quality as the price implies a selector
on the steering wheel lets the driver
choose from four driving modes the
switch that opens and closes the roof
can be found in the center console
this thing really moves explains York
the all wheel drive makes it hard to
make the card drifts as Montes you'd
have to take the car all the way to its
limits there goes one further you need
to take the 911 turbo to its limits and
shut off all the assists to even make
the car enter a drift but drifting is
something best done only by experts and
then mainly on the racetrack
the Porsches purchase price is also
beyond most people's limits the
convertible starts at almost one hundred
eighty eight thousand euros in Germany
compared with that the high expense for
fuel hardly matters Porsche says the 911
Turbo burns an average of nine point
three liters per 100 kilometers but
consumption and everyday driving is
probably much higher not to mention when
you pull out all the stops and put this
performer through its paces Alfa Romeo
is bringing a new version of its Julia
onto the market it comes with a choice
of a turbo diesel with three performance
levels from 100 to 130 two kilowatts and
a v6 twin-turbo gasoline engine that
delivers 375 kilowatts in the Top Model
II quadrifoglio the Italian carmaker
offers the Julia and three different
trim levels prices start at just over
33,000 euros in Germany
mercedes-benz is making its printer even
brawny ur the product range has expanded
to include a version with 5.5 tons of
permitted total weight that means the
Sprinter now covers a broad market
segment from three to five point five
ton vehicles the selection of engines
has also been revised to include a
gasoline a natural gas and for diesel
versions
Audi has been building the q5 since 2008
making it the car maker second oldest
SUV after the q7 to keep the 4.6 meter
car from showing its age it already got
a facelift in 2012 but that's a while
ago now
doughty Khufu's mcafee audi q5 is in the
middle between the q3 in the larger q7
says car testify no dicen hofer it
stands for modern design value retention
and great craftsmanship one out of four
q5 s is sold in the US so howdy plans to
produce the next generation this coming
fall and its new factory in Mexico at
the end of a models lifecycle it's
technically mature several hundred
thousand buyers ensure over the years
that a models every week point is found
and eliminated in the q5 the push of a
button alters the engines response if
you want fuel efficiency the 3.0 TDI
quattro delivers it despite its engine
size according to the e use any DC fuel
consumption cycle the most powerful audi
q5 diesel engine burns just two-tenths
of a liter more per 100 kilometers than
the 2-liter diesel with all-wheel drive
our test cars 190 kilowatts give it a
top speed of 230 kilometers an hour
the q5 is tried and true for long trips
the equiv invest life I hope says the q5
is quiet has outstanding seats and with
its adaptive suspension it can be set
for comfort or sportiness with a maximum
cargo load of four hundred eighty kilos
plenty of luggage can be loaded even if
every seat is taken ya know if you have
to take even more the roof rails will
transport up to 100 kilograms the q5
recognizes the loaded roof rack and
automatically sets the electronic
stability program for a higher center of
gravity and if the driver likes he can
feel safe playing in the mud with the q5
along with the ESP mode for a higher
center of gravity this SUV also has an
off-road anti-lock braking system and
ESP especially for unpaved roads helpful
for off-road driving is also that almost
all engine variations of the q5 are
available with Quattro all-wheel drive
the interiors premium craftsmanship
hasn't changed over the years it feels
as good as it looks
daoudi Koufos the audi q5 is a secure
investments as find hope that goes for
its handling it's timeless design and
its value retention near the end of this
year the successor model will hit the
market that means there are now
attractive trim packages offered for
this model so if you don't have to have
the latest model now is the time to get
your calculator speaking of calculators
of BMW x3 with the same power an all
road drive cost ten thousand euros more
than our test car without extras and the
mercedes GL C which has less power is
still more expensive but who knows
whether Audi can maintain this price
advantage in the next model generation
on the stock market they'd rate the audi
q5 by
thousands of visitors flocked to the
14th edition of the tuning world
bodensee trade fair on Lake Constance to
catch up on the latest trends this year
the tuning scene seems to be divided
into two camps on the one hand there's
the car customizers looking to buff up
older models and on the other are the
new car buyers looking to add some
pizazz to their vehicles but whatever
the reason Germany's automotive
accessories industry is reaping the
benefits with global sales of 4.6
billion euros last year
10 Samuel tuning experts when Schultz
says this year's trend is too old cards
classics and modern classics like
original Beatles older opal cadets
first-generation VW golf's and old
beamers buyers give them modern wheels
and lower bodies taking care not to ruin
the classic lines the car should still
look like it did in the 1970s or 80s
thence when says there's the opposing
trend people buy brand new cars with
powerful engines of BMW m3 or a Golf R
and fit them with a really big Porsche
braking system pricey rims and
performance air or racing suspensions
with it swapping output of 1,500
horsepower this tune 2015 toyota supra
is one of the most powerful cars at the
fair the owner Mateos dijo a car tuner
from Poland has done everything to make
his vehicle lighter and faster he has
spent more than 100,000 euros souping up
his supra
well the carriage meant for drifting oh
this is where we need this power yeah
with that much horsepower it can be a
tricky but still it's a lot of fun mass
market or luxury brand that is the
question here for many the answer is
evident one of the best-selling and
seemingly most two models of all is the
Golf GTI VW celebrated the gulls 40th
anniversary with an area of its own into
fair
like it's all united in this win says
some find that to standard and want
something special if they have the cash
folks take a portion Lamborghini or
Nissan GTR and rebuild it they optimize
a new car straight from the factory with
even better brakes or tweaked its body
that's a fine line to tread some managed
to make the car even nicer though there
are some fo pots to be aware but
generally the camps are divided between
volume brands and high-performance
vehicles which are quite popular these
days when it comes to the likes of
Porsches Lamborghinis for the mercedes
AMG c63s you might think there's nothing
that could be improved upon my god that
is this tutor says to be honest they're
almost perfect when they leave the
factory a new Porsche is already a real
pleasure to drive but people want to
individualize their cars and show their
own taste i smoke i'm outside the result
is something like this a porsche cayman
gt4 than boasts 448 horsepower
performance tires and tuned wheels it's
available for a starting price of 150
thousand euros
this lamborghini aventador super veloce
costs around 350,000 euros it has an
output of 750 horsepower and has been
upgraded with a triple adjustable
coilover suspension plants Iman lives
and dubai and specializes in tuning
luxury cars he says there are lots of
Lamborghinis Porsches and Ferraris
around so to look different from the 20
other Ferrari 458 you've got to do
something that's why they do this
concave wheels have become an absolute
must these premium rims way just a kilo
and cost 370 euros a piece tuning world
also host shows to entertain visitors
dance industry warmed up the crowds with
their LED backlight routines but this
ford mustang GT 5.0 was truly hot at
temperatures of around 30 degrees
celsius its thermal paint transforms the
unassuming car into a real hot ride
alongside all the latest trends the fair
also shows that some things never go out
of style drift shows for instance the
drivers thrilled spectators with their
pirouettes for many tuning world just
wouldn't be complete without the smell
of burning rubber
the Ford a speedster was one of the
earliest models in automobile racing in
the 1920s daredevil men would race round
dusty tracks and vehicles like this one
this 1929 model boasts 40 horsepower and
can reach speeds of 100 kilometers an
hour at a time when most people were
still traveling by horse and carriage it
was revolutionary but for Klaus Miller
speed is not the primary interest it's
the whole driving experience he's been a
lifelong vintage car enthusiast and has
a particular passion for ford cars from
before the Second World War
I'm longer for it's been a long time he
says trying to trace the old racing cars
that were based on the Ford a model but
not produced in Ford factories I
discovered a factory in South America
that specialized in these cars so I went
over there and saw that their cars were
good and authentic and the decision was
made sadness is clicked on Tasha balls
pursuit Klaus Miller ordered a speedster
body from Argentina his goal was to
build an authentic Ford a speedster
parts like the dashboard instruments in
steering wheel he was able to buy at
vintage car markets it took hundreds of
hours of work but eventually he was able
to fulfill his dream
this is all this hump everything has
been put together by hand he says the
bodywork was made without any modern
equipment it was all shaped by hand and
if you look closely you can see lots of
irregularities everything has been done
as it would have been done back then
it's been riveted rather than screwed
together and there are no hollow rivage
the county will Newton's undone I'm for
solving my stomach i'll hit a muffin
conan o taki Marchetti the engine came
from an old Ford a4 1929 Klaus Miller
gave it a complete overhaul before
fitting it into his car
the time for saga finding spare parts is
no problem he says you can basically get
everything there are a few parts that
are no longer produced but you don't
need them anyway all the parts that
we're out you can buy and if
everything's adjusted correctly you can
do the maintenance yourself change the
oil check the spark plugs minor things
like that Tommy's cart- katana Klaus
doesn't believe in just admiring his
cars in the garage he drives his
speedster frequently
the speedster surprisingly normal to
drive he says it's not so different from
modern cars the clutch is the same there
is a three-speed transmission the main
difference is that you're exposed to the
elements and because the noise it's not
so easy to chat with your passenger a
lot of is Alison Gill noise makan
cygnets a license from college mumbai
para the ford a speedster a pre-war
classic with a feel of a racing car and
as they're easy to build and maintain
there are still quite a number of model
a's around today
you